we finally have indictments in the
Muller investigation related to meddling
in the 2016 election and the only ones
being charged are Russians a federal
grand jury has now indicted 13 Russian
individuals and companies for
interfering in the 2016 election they're
charged with a bunch of things like
creating fake ads staging Pro and anti
Trump campaign events and also setting
up bogus front organizations but they're
not accused of rigging the election for
Trump but instead of waging information
warfare to sow discord in the political
system Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein announced the indictments and
added this important caveat there is no
allegation in this indictment that any
American was a knowing participant in
this illegal activity there is no
allegation in the indictment that the
charged conduct altered the outcome of
the 2016 election did you hear that no
American knowingly took part in the
meddling and the plot had no effect on
the outcome of the election the facts as
we know them right now support the
president's argument an argument we've
been making on this show for months that
there was no Russian collusion Trump not
surprisingly took a bit of a victory lap
tweeting today Russia started their anti
US campaign in 2014 long before I
announced that I would run for president
the results of the election were not
impacted the Trump campaign did nothing
wrong no collusion well it certainly
looks that way but we don't know for
sure what else Muller may have up his
sleeve though I'll tell you who this
totally vindicates conservatives and
Republicans who've been warning people
for years about how devious the Russians
can be in this situation remember when
President Obama sarcastically mocked
Mitt Romney's Russia warning back in 22
during the presidential debate when you
were asked what's the biggest
geopolitical threat facing America you
said Russia not al-qaeda you said Russia
and the 1980s are now calling to ask for
their foreign policy back because the
Cold War has been over for 20 years now
Obama was so convinced of that his DOJ
and FBI did next to nothing about the
Russian skullduggery I love that word
his State Department actually approved
by the way the visas for the Russian
operatives that were indicted by Muller
today his FBI began spying on Trump
campaign advisor Carter page with a FISA
warrant in the fall of 2016
now details in today's indictment do
point to vindication for the Trump team
this is Jonathan Turley from tonight's
special report this makes more sense
than the narratives that everyone's been
throwing around and conspiracies this
began in 2014 began before the
presidential election the Russians were
taking targets of opportunity and they
were shooting at everybody in the
election but they were certainly working
more against Hillary Clinton but what it
does show is that they did a really
quite an impressive job in finding this
cyber trail to these individuals I'll
say and the indictment describes rallies
that took place after the election both
in support of and against Trump and by
the way some of them happen on the same
day all allegedly promoted by these
Russian accounts you see this ad
well according to BuzzFeed this anti
Trump rally states just four days after
the election was promoted by something
called black matters u.s. a social media
campaign thought to be organized by
Russians so why would Trump collude with
Russians to stage anti Trump rallies
does that make any sense here's the
bottom line
the Trump campaign did not know about
Russian interference in the u.s.
election but the Obama administration
certainly did and may have in fact
enabled it
given that we already know Hillary
Clinton's campaign and the DNC paid for
that fake Russian dossier which was a
major predicate for the entire Muller
investigation
it's time for the Special Counsel to
interview Hillary Clinton John Kerry
Susan Rice Ben Rhodes and maybe even
Barack Obama I say it's high time that
we determine who really colluded with
the Russians